This is what happens when we set the step size to 2 days,
which look pretty reasonable with the original curves.
This is what we get--the numbers explode to 1.4 * 10⁷⁹--that doesn't look too good.
In case you're wondering about the conservation of the total number,
some of these variables get huge in a positive direction
and some of these get huge at the negative direction.
Actually, the total number stays pretty much constant
at the price of some of these becoming negative.
With a step size of 1.9 days, which is the solution, we don't see an explosion, the number stays limited
but the behavior is, of course, highly implausible.
Now, we look into what's going wrong here.